foreign
[Music]
laughs
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
laughs
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
state of play of 2023. we've got a lot
to show you including an in-depth demo
of Suicide Squad kill the Justice League
but first PlayStation VR2 is finally
here let's Dive Right In with a look at
five games arriving on Playstation VR2
this year
let's see how you do this time
kid we gotta work on your focus
Jam they'll get you killed out there
remember what we shook on or
I guess we'll just have to keep this up
no no
no no try again shall we
[Music]
believe
immune to all your weapons now
[Music]
foreign
this may be hard to hear
the Empire will fall
our galaxy will be plunged into thirty
thousand years of chaos and War
but there is a plan to save Humanity
[Music]
so will you fight for a dying Empire
or help us
to reach Foundation
[Music]
now you see that tower out there big
scary one
that's where I'm taking you to see
gatekeeper
to be judged
your life you're gonna show it to me
just think back to the very beginning
the first thing that you can remember
every time you blink you're going to
jump forward in time
hey you come over here
is that really you it it's Chloe your
neighbor
only way to fight against time is create
a work of Genius which might live on
after you're gone
your eyes now
enclosed
it's only a matter of time
you're ashamed of something something so
terrible you're trying to Blink right
past it
now the next time that you blink I'm
gonna send you back
and just try to enjoy it this time
that was a sneak peek at some great
upcoming games for PlayStation VR2
up next Bungie gives us a stunning new
look at Destiny 2 lightfall which
Launches on PS5 next week
[Music]
what is that
the witness
[Music]
a first collapse
is at our doorstep
here I have no purpose nervous because
you fear to seek once
is your failure
thank God
the enemy away from the traveler at all
costs
not all of us have lives to spare
your fear
s
[Music]
battle begins Here and Now
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
of many shots
[Music]
Chia is one of our most anticipated
games and it's launching into the
Playstation Plus game catalog in March
speaking of PlayStation Plus let's take
a look at what's in store next month
[Music]
get down
our next game is from enhance the
creators of Tetris effect and res
infinite
[Music]
thank you
la la
foreign
[Music]
speech at the assembly in light of the
whole Space Rock potential demise of
civilization thing My Chosen theme feels
off what's the theme using this year to
make an impact yeah yeah perfect go with
that are you okay you've come into this
year kind of intense with the band stuff
the band is important
why did she have to just leave
I said it was an emergency you did and
it is
to you
[Music]
possessions
it's weird how everyone's acting like
nothing is different
but to me Everything feels different now
we've always done what you wanted to do
and that's fine
[Music]
time we have left how are we supposed to
just be fine
[Music]
I'm not gonna lose you hear me now I'll
just cut you off completely
I'll inherit my Master's will
you can't defeat me no matter what you
become I Will Always Love You the Hokage
is the person who walks in front of
everyone and Bears all the pain
[Music]
why are you so obsessed with me
because we're friends
here we go
in a Flash huh my blood is boiling
charge no despair you can't escape how
about this
move I win don't underestimate the will
a fight I'll settle this now is the hour
of judgment
this is
prepare yourself sweet dreams how about
this you'll be eaten alive
idiots Church
from here forth history will be spun
again and so began their Journey
on a path with no end
of this power I will establish perfect
order what you describe as nothing more
than oppression through force and fear
my frail little brother no
I do not wish to fight you elder brother
captivating fantasy worlds await in our
next two games
I'll tell you a story true soul
my life was dismantled piece by piece
and when I tried to buy it back it cost
me everything
I must finish what I started
death's design will be complete
discover Catholic secret
find out what it is that makes him
invincible so we can strip him off his
advantage
WWE
[Music]
you're upon a slave to forces you cannot
comprehend
Patrick is a frightening man but you
have something he doesn't allies worth
having together we will strike down the
absolute
oh
[Music]
bow before me
bow before the absolute bow
[Music]
welcome to wayfinder an online
multiplayer adventure for you and your
friends it's all set in evanor a
gorgeous but Fallen World
you'll Control the Chaos through
wayfinders
meet senja who likes to get up close and
personal and Silent who fights with both
Firepower and fast reflexes
and windraved slices through the frame
while also supporting the group
booked another Victory under our belts
let's head to head to light our Social
Hub here you'll turn your loot into new
weapons and wayfinders you can also
explore dungeons called Lost zones that
you can modify and mutate for a greater
challenge
lost zones are for you and your friends
will team up to complete quests collect
Loot and Hunt bosses like this Titan
we're excited to bring wayfinders beta
exclusively to PlayStation and you can
sign up for the chance to play early now
thanks for watching
foreign
we've got big updates on two highly
anticipated Capcom games starting with
the debut of three new characters for
Street Fighter 6.
[Music]
brace yourself
useless
[Music]
this is your last flight let's go
better
[Music]
I call upon you great to win
the spirit of the Wind
let yourself become one week
[Music]
here I go
the voice of this Spirit only I can hear
it
but not the one we're looking for
[Music]
foreign
another mission awaits
[Music]
you see we are all connected through the
holy body
when you need only accept a sacred gift
[Music]
Christ
like
like she did
Temperance child
taking delivery preparing some
entertainment for you ah the
entertainment without further Ado the
gallon night protects the princess bear
I'm making tea for you move
she's always like this with you how
about you open fire instead of your
mouth
long time no see Richard krauser why
you can't save her
you can't save anyone
gonna happen with me
you gotta keep moving forward we will
beat this
together
thanks
let us rescue the princess you gotta
hurt yourself
ha
it's kind of fun
ahead you're kidding
ah yes the time has come
like I told you
I'm gonna get you home safe
oh Leah
and let it be soft
this time
it has to be different
foreign
[Music]
the show's not over yet it's Harley
Quinn Deadshot king shark and Captain
Boomerang against the world's greatest
DC superheroes in this extended look at
Suicide Squad kill the Justice League
let's hear from developer Rocksteady
Studios foreign
and I'm the studio product director at
Rocksteady Studios Suicide Squad killed
the Justice League is the next
installment in the Arkham verse and
we'll be releasing this may
it is a third person action shooter set
five years after the events of Batman
Arkham Knight Metropolis has been
invaded and you're going in as The
Suicide Squad members Harley Quinn King
sharp Deadshot and Captain Boomerang to
face off against the ultimate threat a
corrupted Justice League
the team has been hard at work at
creating the best possible game
experience for our players and we're
very excited to share more as part of
this state of play today let's take a
brief look at one of the missions in our
game The Flash has been corrupted by
brainier and as The Suicide Squad you'll
need to work together in up to four
player online co-op to stop the Flash
and rescue Lex Luthor in the process
enjoy
let's [__] something up
oh you know what
hold on a sec
hello Brainiac
is it happening now
great you will have Luther ASAP
you want Luther all you have to to do is
come and get him
task force x what the hell was that
flash is alive and he has Luther one
damn thing at a time
that artillery is going to wreak havoc
on our front line if there's a
snowball's chance in hell you can
destroy it I expect you to no matter the
cost are we clear
yeah
where the snowball
time to light them all up
on my way
all my big guys let's dance
oh
that's gonna leave a mark
yeah focus on fire on this tank why do
we never get reinforcements
go
senseless violence love it
[__] Squad no worries
boom job done you came through Boomer
just call me the Pinball Wizard
Unstoppable
thank you
[Music]
Rising like a wave
this is a chance
ouch I love our escapades
foreign
[Music]
taking down the flash thing go
still in play
let me get out of my way I have work to
do
well hey there sleepyhead we've got an
interrogation to get back to
you think I'm just gonna let you walk
away
until these guys everything you know
you think they can stop us
pathetic
at least I'm not a big hero turn stooge
for a space man
ah
okay boomerang
you want to see what a real hero can do
I'll show you
flash how do I stop this
please tell me how
to kill us Diana
we have to die
to save the world
[Music]
Suicide Squad killed the Justice League
arrives on PS5 May 26th
Rocksteady Studios has even more to
share today let's listen in
show me what you got
Suicide Squad kill Justice League is an
extension of the Arkham verse and it's
really about now reframing the story and
telling it from the villain's point of
view where are we going and who are we
killing it's a mixture of lots of the
things I hope the fans like about
Rocksteady but like a whole massive
chunk of new stuff that they've never
seen before
we've always seen Batman's perspective
on this world and we thought it'd be
really fun and enjoyable to see this
universe but Through The Eyes of the
villains
the story five years after the end of
Arkham Knight and A lot's changed in
that time just checking we're all seeing
that thing right Brainiac has invaded
Earth and he's this huge threat
overlooking Metropolis he's taken over
Metropolis City the Justice League are
there to try and save the city but
Brainiac has captured and brainwashed
them and turned them against the very
people they've been sworn to protect oh
[__] Superman
so the Justice League share the same
goal as a brainiac to take over Earth
and turn it into the nucleus what we've
created is a classic Justice League but
with the sense that there's something
wrong with them they are now doing
brainiacs bidding and Amanda Waller
scrambles to try to remedy this and
essentially save the Earth and she
recruits for lovable characters into
fighting the Justice League in an effort
to reclaim the Earth and thwartz
brainiac's plans your new mission is to
kill the Justice League the members of
The Suicide Squad are Harley Quinn
Captain Boomerang Deadshot and king
shark Harley Quinn is definitely the
most acrobatic of the cruise she's
always moving she's always flying
through the air and barely controlled
ways the feeling of swinging and the
momentum and the kind of physicality of
it and trying to keep that momentum
going and use that to go over buildings
or swing under bridges and shine that
into kind of the grapple mechanic that
she's got it just feels it's got on
I'm a freaking
shot has the iconic Deadshot look but
with a rock steady twist it's got a real
Swagger to him and in this game we can
also hover with his jet pack in super
precise he uses sniper rifles assault
rifles and pistols and they all fit with
his sort of the fantasy of playing as
Deadshot as this master assassin but you
want team waller or team get the hell
out of this mess king shark to me as as
a person is well that's a fish is this
incredible character who's super well
read and super well to do and I'm sure
could smash an operatic performance
actually I'm the son of a god
is my shame to suffer Mortals in their
buffoonery but also doesn't really know
simple words or simple things that are
going on I think that's brilliant in
terms of combat he is a brute he's a
tank character he can take more damage
his abilities will lean into the fact
that he wants to get in a bit more close
and personal he's the fastest Melee
character
Captain boomerang's got his speed force
Gauntlet that he can use together with
his boomerang he can throw it to any
point in space and speed force to that
point along the walls along the floor
and get wherever he wants to go you can
use that get up close Dodge around in
midair taking out the enemies and then
Scarlet because he doesn't want to stick
around don't worry guys I'm here one of
the most exciting parts that connects
our game to the DC lore are the support
Squad he's all Widow and you have
penguin the arm stealer you're making
guns for us now bird brain but also some
new faces pack who is a digital ghost
that is helping the squad both navigate
the world but also upgrade their neck
bombs that's a big adrenaline Spike you
on a nice bomb sending out this toy man
who's helping the squad with perfecting
gear and then finally we have Gizmo who
is helping the squad with insane vehicle
Creations that let you blow [__] up
Metropolis is your playground you're
going to get to meet different
characters different villains and you
really get to see these cool iconic
locations being the city of Tomorrow
kind of like meant stark contrast with
good MCT which is very dirty it's always
raining and that contrasts with like a
city that's very Grand it's very clean
it's very functional the huge difference
between metropolis and Gotham is that
Metropolis really acknowledge and really
trust Superman so there's a lot of
statues to thank Superman for everything
is done for the city you're getting to
see Metropolis through the villain's
eyes you're going to experience this
world and Traverse view this world as
the villains
Metropolis to the core ability that
everything wraps around in Suicide Squad
is your traversal how that works with
combat is you're chaining your combat
moves together with those reversal moves
and the combat encounters are all
designed to push and pull you around the
environment in a battlefield that's
constantly changing working out how to
use all your different weapons your guns
your melee attacks and how to use them
all to your best advantage to control
the chaos and come out Victorious what's
awesome about Gunplay is the variety so
there's six core types of weapon
families we've got assault rifles SMGs
sniper rifles shotguns miniguns and
pistols there's added variety from
weapon manufacturers there's lexcorp
weapons there's gcpe weapons there's
armor attack weapons later on in the
game we also have gear sets like gear
sets are villain themed for example if
you have a bane gear set and you trigger
his Buffs in the game some of it will
have the Bane drowns and you will like
burn and like boom boom boom and then
and there's like green smoke and you
trigger all kind of effects so you're
basically taking the essence of the
villain you're bringing it into the game
each character has a power level in the
game that we call dear score as you
acquire new gear in the game your gear
score goes up and as that number goes up
it means that you can take how much
harder missions the as part of this
progression Journey you will unlock more
and more builds more and more ways to
customize your character to really fit
the way you want to play every firearm
in our game is upgradable so in Suicide
Squad killer Justice League you're gonna
get lots of choice to use the weapons
that you need and to complete your
missions but most importantly you will
be able to customize your squad to be
whatever you like you can wear whatever
you want any of the outfits you can be
running around in your Asylum jail
outfit and still have like the best gear
score ever I like it our game is a one
to four player co-op experience which
means that all the missions in the game
have been designed to support solo play
playing with a friend two friends or
three friends for the single player fans
you can play it in single player with
Bots filling in the role of the squad so
you still feel like you're part of a
team and you can switch them if you want
and try king shark now or we can say
well I think Harley will be a better fit
for this Mission so I'm going to switch
over and try her out
but if you really want to tear it up
going in with a full group of four lets
you experience the full Mayhem the
suicide squad has to offer and you get
to really experience the Dynamics
between how you can all play together in
different play Styles in order to take
on Brainiac and the Justice League
all the fun is right here when the
story's done your experience doesn't end
there Rocksteady will continue its
Legacy of supporting the game after it's
launched we're going to deliver lots of
new content to our players we're going
to have new playable characters new
weapons and New Missions for players who
like to customize their looks we'll
offer a battle pass that only contains
cosmetic items there's just gonna be so
much for the players to enjoy yeah yeah
picture it Harley Quinn kills the
Justice League if you like story games
if you like RPG elements if you like
co-op games if you like customizing your
characters if you want a place a badass
this game kind of has it all it's very
fast paced it's really colorful it's
loud and Unapologetic and in your face
and it's going to be really really fun
hey Macho
you like live executions well don't
touch that dial or I'll break your
fingers
Suicide Squad kill the Justice League
arrives on PS5 later this year we'll be
back with more announcements soon thanks
for watching
[Music]
PlayStation